من جانبه قال عضو المكتب السياسي لجماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين ان قصف التحالف
الامريكي البريطاني لمحافظات يمنيه لن
يغير موقف الجماعه ولن يوقف عمليتها
العسكريه التي تقوم بها ضد اسرائيل حتى
تتوقف الاباده الجماعيه في قطاع غزه ويرفع
الحصار عن سكان القطاع واضاف البخيتي في
منشور له على منصه اكس ان العدوان
الامريكيه البريطانيه على اليمن لن يمر
دون رد ان الجماعه ستقابل التصعيد
بالتصعيد على حد
تعبيره لمزيد من المتابعه معنا من صنعاء
مراسل الجزيره محمد العطاب محمد اذا لن
يغير هذا الهجوم الاخير من قواعد اللعبه
بالنسبه للحوثيين لن يغير من المعادله
شيئا سيستمر الحوثيون في استهداف السفن
الاسرائيليه المتجهه الى الاراضي
الفلسطينيه المحتله ماذا في
التفاصيل نعم كما يؤكد الحوثيون وفي خلال
الضربات السابقه فيانه كلما
استمرت التحالف الثنائي البريطاني
الامريكي في قيام بغارات والتصعيد يقولون
بانها ستواجه التصعيد بالتصعيد كما ايضا
اكد جماعه انصار الله الحين خلال خطابه
الاخير بانه كل مره تقوم
بها يقوم بها التحالف الثنائي الامريكي
البريطاني بعمليات وغارات هم في انفسهم
يصنعون ويحدثون قدراتهم
وصناعاتهم اكد في ان بان العمليات الاخيره
التي تم القيام بها قامت به جماعتهم في
البحر الاحمر كان استخدم ايضا صواريخ
جديده طولت وحدثت خلال
فترات الاستهداف البريطاني الامريكي
يؤكدون بانه كلما كانت الحرب اشد كلما
كانوا هم اقوى واشد في خصوص تطوير قدراتهم
وايضا
وبطريقه مرنه التصرف وا الابعاد عن
الاماكن التي يمكن ان تستهدف معظم المناطق
التي استهدفت هذه الليله تعتبر بحسب
تصريحاتهم ب انها مناطق اصبحت خاليه وكانت
تعد معسكرات
لنظام نظام عسكري مؤسسي لكن انهم يتبعون
خطوات او اجراءات النظام او الحرب
الجوريلا وور وهي حرب تعتمد على حرب ما
يسمى بحرب بحرب الغابات او حرب الجماعات
الصغيره
المتوزعة وايضا مناطق اخرى في الح في
الحديده استهدفت عده مناطق على تقع على
بالقرب من الساحل البحر الاحمر ومن ضمنها
الدريهمي واللحيه والصليب واعتبر
الامريكيون بانهم استهدفوا من خلال هذه
العمليات في المناطق القريبه من البحر
الاحمر انهم استهدفوا مناطق
لاطلاق الطائرات المسيره وايضا الصواريخ
فيما استهدفوا ايضا في مناطق تعز ما
يقولون ويؤكدون بانها مناطق تحكم وهناك
استخدم استدي شبكه اتصالات حسب بعض
المساطر وهي في في مقبنه وايضا في جبل
حيفان واستهدف ايضا في في منطقه البحر
البرح وحيث نالت البرح وحيف معظم نصيب
الاسد من الغارات حيث استهدفت باكثر من 11
غاره وفي صنعاء كان نصيب الاسد لجبل عطان
وهو اول هدف يستهدف من قبل التحالف
الثنائي البريطاني الامريكي نحن الان في
في مرحله تصعيد مقابل تصعيد كل مره يصعد
فيها التحالف الثنائي البريطاني الامريكي
نشاهد تصعيد من قبل جماعه الانصار لا ففي
البحر الاحمر استهدفوا مؤخرا السفينه
البريطانيه لوانا وظلت تحترق لليلتين
وايضا
استهدفوا بارجه حربيه تابعه لواشنطن
وهي والتي تسمى يو
اسفلي ف السابق كانت العمليات تستهدف فقط
او تحذر المتجه الى اسرائيل الان نشهد
بسبب ما تقوله جماعه الانصار بان هذه
السفن تحمي السفن الي تريد ان تذهب باتجاه
اسرائيل فالان نشهد تصعيدا وايضا هناك
مطالبات من قبل المتظاهرين الذين
خرجوا البارحه ايضا انه يستمر هذا التصعيد
من قبل جماعه انصار الله حتى ترضخ اسرائيل
لمطالب حكومه صنعاء وهي رفع الحصار وانهاء
عدوانها على اهالي غزه لاا